so jordan one of the things that you
talk about in the book which is i think
really wonderful is sort of the
relationship question you know how do
you maintain romance in your
relationship and as a dude who's been
married for almost 13 years at this
point i can say that you know it is very
very good advice i mean the amount of
work that has to go into a relationship
to keep a relationship functioning at a
high level is tremendous and that's not
what you are sold in the media what
you're sold in the media is number one
the happily ever after wedding ending
but even that is now hacked now the idea
is that there is no happily ever after
that basically you're a fool if you get
married and that true happiness lies in
changing partners on a fairly routine
basis but that's not the case that you
make at all you make the case that
happiness is going to lie and
fulfillment more importantly is going to
lie in the hard work of of putting
romance into your relationship and
i had a lot of clinical experience you
know and i had
men in my practice who were
very successful serially sexually active
and
it didn't work for them very well now
i would say
very forthrightly
if i had two men and
all other things being equal one
was capable of serial sexual
relationships and was attractive enough
to manage that and the other wasn't that
the person who
managed to do that is more successful i
believe that
so if you're abstinent because you're
incapable that is not a virtue
but
you can't divorce something as
miraculous
as sexuality from your life
how are you gonna do that well you can
trivialize it
it's nothing well okay well then then
then you have nothing so
good luck with that you're gonna take
one of the deepest sources of meaning
that's available to you and turn it into
nothing well
that's its own punishment
well so then you integrate it into your
life well what do you want for your life
dude do you want intimacy do you want
closeness
do you even want the experience to be of
high quality do you want the person to
pay attention to you
well they're gonna have to care for you
i mean lust will get you somewhere and
it's not nothing
but it's by no means everything
and
and everyone knows this
people are lonely
they they need and they need someone to
communicate with and they need someone
to tie
themselves together with so their lives
make a rope they need someone to
communicate with when times are good and
to share their
triumphs and they need someone to
share their catastrophes and they need a
framework that's stable so that they can
have children and well why would you
have children it's like that's a stupid
question it's like well what else are
you gonna do
you know i mean there aren't that many
things that make up your life and
intimate relationships that's 20 of your
life for 30 of your life children that's
20 of your life now you can get away
with neither of those but you better
have a walloping career or a tremendous
aptitude at something
creative and remarkable and maybe you
can do that maybe that'll be enough for
you but i've seen that unit
dimensionality work out well very very
very very very rarely
you'll never have the opportunity in
your life to have as high quality
relationship with anyone as you could
potentially have with your child
so you're going to forego that well you
can but
what's left for you then young people
are being sold a shoddy bill of goods
even if you're successful at what you
pursue
you're a hot tinder item
it's like well if you're a male and
you're attractive and you have an
endless array of willing females it's a
gateway to psychopathy as far as i'm
concerned
because you have to divorce your
sexuality from the humanity of the
people that you're
engaged with sexually well all that's
going to do is make you hard and bitter
and i wouldn't recommend it
i'm not suggesting that
naive abstinence
is the right solution
we're not doing a good job ben of of
communicating the fundamental values of
life to you our young
you